vince velasquez his 16th start
three and four in era of 5.00
big sigh from velazquez and his first
pitch is whacked into center field one
pitch one hit here we
got a good spot on the outside corner
according to angel hernandez
here's freddie freeman with that
incredible
contact streak working for the braves
first baseman and he unloads deep to
right field that one's not coming back
off the facade of the second deck it's
two nothing atlanta he's been covering
both sides of the plate
barreling everything and this ball is
absolutely destroyed
riley strikes out second strikeout for
vince
dansby swanson waves at that one three
strikeouts in the inning
true smiley fellas is on quite a roll
he's won five consecutive decisions
that's the longest win streak by any
brave starter in 2021
and a swing and a miss zagara chased
smiley off to a good start one up one
down
he got him swinging a miss ryan muto
upset wasn't a strike chased it anyway
two up two down two-two to harper
shoots it the other way
almante it's over his head a one-hop off
the yingling side and harper's on his
way to second he's there a two out
double
[Applause]
mccutcheon to left bud almante's there
and that will retire the side
that'll bring abraham almante up to the
plate to see mince velazquez
[Music]
swing and he belts one deep right field
that one's not coming back
three nothing atlanta
what a swing by el monte last home run
june 7th
been in a little bit of a slump they
tried to go slide her away where angel
hernandez gave him that pitch off the
plate misses middle
in velasquez nose right off the bat
line drive by freeman he does it again
freddie is two for two
not going
and it missed badly inside riley takes
ball four the inning continues first and
second with one out dansby swanson
all for one tonight
swinging a shot into the left field
corner that's gonna score freddie
freeman riley on his way to third he is
going to be held dansby swanson with a
double three straight braves have
reached and they've extended the lead to
four to nothing and the crowd in philly
tells you all you need to know
and it's brandon kinsler and he's coming
in in a rather difficult spot in the
game this is abraham's second career
appearance against brandon kinsler he's
one for one against him
swinging a shot in the right center
field that's down for a hit that's gonna
score two
almante is having a great game he's
driven home three and atlanta extends
the lead it is six nothing and all of
those runs belong to vince velazquez
eugene lines one back through the middle
of base hit
and a swing and a miss
harper looks back and says how do they
miss it
mccutchen draws a walk
as a base runner you look at it you
think it might be a bar
there's the ball that's a bomb yeah
absolutely three umpires watching all
four called it and
30 guys in a dugout
and ball four that'll put two on
back-to-back walks
all four three straight walks
back to the bound out at the plate
and out at first
one two three double play
breaking ball popped him up
into shallow left and drew smiley with
one of the great houdini acts of the
year
loads him up with three walks a double
play and a pop out preserves the shutout
and a lead true smiley with a six run
lead through four innings is taken down
for josh tomlin here
and a live drive base hit from real muto
into right field a two out single
harper to left almonte is there and josh
tomlin breezes through the fifth inning
that's a fair ball over the bag down the
right field line almante on his way to
second to throw by over he is out
he's out at second
9-6 on the put out
maybe mr almante thought you know if i
get a double here i'm i'm one hit i'm
one trip away from the cycle
and he walks already out so
josh tomlin we presume is gonna come on
and he lays it down perfectly there's
one play
and a sinker thrown away and tomlin is
on his way to second and the braves have
him second and third
six nothing early braves trying to tack
on a couple more here the infield comes
in with peterson up first pitch ground
ball up the middle a base hit heredia
scores and here comes tomlin around
third he slams on the brakes and
peterson never stopped running he takes
second
line drive out to right field base hit
some mccutcheon's aboard greece hoskins
coming up
as reece lines one out towards center
field going back on it as heredia still
going back it's over his head at one hop
off the wall mccutcheon a third he's
being waved on by dusty
the throw by all these will not arrive
rbi double by reece the phillies are
finally on the board
three balls in a strike for swanson
and he hits one high in the air toward
left center field that's out toward the
triangle that's gonna ricochet around
herrera picks it up cleanly but not
before dansby picks up his second double
of the night
fly ball left field
hit pretty well playable though for
mccutchen about three steps from the
track
let's see if ozzie can get in on the
hitting fun
and the braves are frolicking tonight
and ozzie on loads deep to right field
high leverage high and gone off the
facade of the second deck
ozzy obese extends his hitting streak to
four games with his 16th home run
and the braves are pouring it on it's
ten to one in the eighth
ronald thereas a position player is
gonna pitch here in the eighth inning
for the phillies top of the eighth
inning
riley unloads
68 coming in
about 108 going out into the second deck
a two-run homer for riley
and the braves are bombing away in south
philly it's 12-1
check swing ground ball to second all
these bobbles kicks it everybody's safe
a run scores
it's 12-2
lines it out to center field already is
there makes the catch tagging from third
is hoskins throw goes to third sac fly
for the pitcher
so back to the top of the order jack
peterson in search of a four hit night
uh-oh jack peterson unloads that one's
gonna go a long way that one's out of
here
peterson has four hits
he's hit the fifth homer of the night
for atlanta
and that's the second one given up by
thereas
and the braves are
pummeling the phillies tonight it's 15-3